-How was it?
I know you did -- Like a lot
of us, like myself,
you did your show at home
for a while.
You were hesitant to do that.
How'd it work out?
-Not.
-[ Laughs ]
-You don't like watching people
do their shows
from home, correct?
-Well, my thing is, I don't know
how big your home is
and how much space you have,
but I live in
an apartment, you know?
Not my fault.
But I live in an apartment,
and it was very
personal to me...
-Sure.
-...for people to see,
you know, my area.
And people criticized and
couldn't understand my groove.
And then we
just stopped doing that
because we were ramping up for
new stuff, new season,
new "Wendy."
-Now, part of this new season,
this new "Wendy"
that we're all so excited to
see, you know,
obviously, one thing that
will be lacking is an audience.
And having done your show --
and I know we've talked about
this before -- what you create
is more than just people
who are there to see a show.
It is a full party that is
happening in the A.M.
The energy is so contagious,
so much fun to be around.
I imagine that you're --
you're going to miss it.
-No.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ] No.
You know what?
I come from radio, and on radio,
you only have a microphone
and you in a booth,
until you don't.
Like, this right here
is something else to me.
But I'm still only used to
talking to me in my head
and you looking at the camera.
So it's not a big deal
not to have an audience.
I can't wait for my co-host
to be back.
But right now, we are on total
lockdown here at the show.
Everyone, including me.
We get three different tests
every single day,
and that's the way it goes.
And it's not just this building.
It's the one across the street.
-That's great.
Obviously, it's really important
to put safety above all else.
But you have figured out
you are going to still do
the "Ask Wendy" segment that
we've all come to rely on.
-Yeah, they'll figure that out.
You know, Seth, that's what
we have producers for.
-Sure.
-Call in people,
ask them some questions,
and we'll do "Ask Wendy."
-That's great.
Yeah, people like you and I --
we don't have to get
caught up in the details.
We have a staff for that.
They're a lot smarter than us.
They can solve our problems.
-That's what I say.
-Is it at least nice to be
back in a room where --
I mean, I have found, you know,
being around
my crew again,
being around producers,
people that are so good at this,
have you been happy
to do that again?
-I love it.
We missed Guns N' Roses
this summer,
which I'm pissed.
You know, I was supposed to be
bringing them,
and we were going to be going.
And I'm also upset that
you're actually seeing
a new background right here.
But that's all you'll get,
Seth, nothing else.
-I'm very -- I have a question
about the Wendy mug
that's next to you.
-Mm-hmm.
-Is that lipstick
on the side of it
that is put there by design?
-Correct.
-That's really
a beautiful design.
-And then the other one says
nothing, except for "Wendy."
-That's good.
I think the key is to get across
that you're the host
of the show, and it really --
I can't tell you how clear that
is based on the both the --
-Right?
-What?
-It's good.
-It's great.
Wendy, I don't want this
to come off as accusatory,
but I've heard tell that one of
the ways you pass time
in your apartment is
looking at people
out your window with binoculars.
Is this true, Wendy?
-Correct.
-And what have you seen of
your fellow New Yorkers
in doing this?
-Well, there is an apartment
building across,
and the man takes showers
and the shower is
right there at the window.
And I watch.
-So, what are you seeing?
I'm assuming the window
isn't, you know, head-to-toe.
-No. It's a head-to-ankle.
-Well, that's still most of
the good parts.
Now, Wendy, when I heard
you were looking at people
with the binoculars, I thought
it was about passersby,
but I feel like what
you're doing now
is, like, borderline criminal.
-I peep and I Tom.
-Alright. Well, you know what?
You own it,
and I find there's something --
There is something
noble in that.
How do you -- Do you miss
interviewing people in person?
-Huh?
-Do you miss interviewing
people in person?
-Yeah. Like, this is weird.
Only because we're on the thing.
-Yeah.
-But not really,
because I already knew you.
-It's true.
-Like, I don't want to meet
people this way.
-It's very true.
It's a lot easier with people
that you've already met
versus ones you're meeting
for the first time.
-By the way, Seth,
you look really handsome.
-Thank you very much, Wendy.
That is always nice to hear,
especially from you,
because, as we've established
over the course
of this interview,
you call it like you see it.
-Yep.
-Wendy, I cannot stress enough
how excited I am
for your show
to be back on Monday.
12 seasons -- that's an
incredible accomplishment.
I do -- As much as
I want my audience back,
I want your audience back,
because it is so much fun
to watch how happy
people are to be
in the same room with you.
Thank you for being here.
-How do I look again?
-You look fantastic.
Resplendent.
-Thank you, Seth.